queen apparently your report didn't want
megan at phillips funeral why well she
was didn't want to be the attention
diverted from philip if megan had been
there she would have got all the
attention i mean the harry walk up the
hill with uh william was that just
showed how the media was focused on the
reconciliation and everything after
oprah so when she said to one of her
aides thank goodness megan isn't coming
she meant it the heartfelt was it the
queen that kicked them off the balcony
at the jubilee well i think with the
queen but also i'm sure charles and
william had a big say that they weren't
going to allow netflix to dominate their
their big celebration i really can't
stand the climate lecture from somebody
who took a private jet most assuredly to
go give that speech
i i can't believe i mean if we compared
my climate footprint to his there'd be
no comparison whatsoever and look if i
had private jet money i'd take a private
jet he obviously was born into those
kinds of connections and if you're born
a prince you generally have advantages
that almost no one else will have to
make your life whatever it is that you
want and to do whatever it is you want
with maybe one exception and that is to
be a professional victim
which unfortunately seems to be the
career path that he's most attracted to
is he is whining at every chance he gets
about almost everything non-stop without
offering any sort of solution or even
acknowledgement for the way some of his
own behavior might contribute to the
problems he's complaining about right he
also likened his struggle for freedom to
nelson mandela's who just remind
everybody spent 27 years in a 6x6 prison
cell do you see any obvious parallels
between their battles for freedom
of course not there are no parallels at
all
up here
because you'll see one is obviously
fighting for
the dignity of black people
against a vicious tyrant like apartheid
obviously as opposed to one finding
their own identity outside a said
institution
uh obviously these are very different
things but i guess you know how you
define freedom for an individual is is
can be can be different
and maybe for them it was a real
struggle to finally make that decision
number one and to also be able to carry
out i mean just because you got that
decision it's always easier said than
done so to some extent maybe that's how
they felt uh obviously those are
definitely two worlds apart when you got
to the end of the book did you have any
sympathy for meghan markle did you buy
into her thing that she had no idea what
she's really getting into oh on the
contrary i think she's a very scheming
very
clever woman no i think the surprisingly
at the end of the book i realized how
successful she'd been here was a woman
who was nothing i mean born broken
family the whole thing
uh an actual unknown actress all the
rest of it becomes a global star which
is what she wanted when she was about to
nine or ten she said to her father i
want to be famous i want to walk down
the red carpet and she has now done that
and she's
calculated that she could be a great
success and and by marrying harry
she did it and so are they in trouble
now though is the sussex brand on the
downward side a lot of american friends
of mine are completely done with them
which they weren't even sure again sure
and this may this book may
hasten a downward trend yeah if i wish i
wouldn't be sad at all because they pose
a real threat
to the royal family that's what i've
felt from this the reason i've been so
exercised about them is i think they are
destroying
a lot of the magic of the monarchy
they're calling the royals a bunch of
callus racists and so on without
producing any hard evidence to support
any of these other countries and it's
incredibly damaging actually telling
untruths yeah and i think that was
terrible that's really why i wrote the
book because i just thought this woman
is really doing something quite dreadful
to britain and harry has fallen in love
with her in a ludicrous way and has gone
along with her accomplice we're living
through a pandemic that continues to
ravage communities in every corner of
the globe
climate change wreaking havoc on our
planet
with the most vulnerable suffering most
of all
the few weaponizing lies and
disinformation at the expense of the
many
and from the horrific war in ukraine
to the rolling back of constitutional
rights here in the united states we are
witnessing a global assault on democracy
and freedom
we are witnessing a global assault
democracy and you have all got to take
climate change seriously even if i use
private jets like a taxi service
do you hear me all of you
do you
when did he become this miserable guy
he's so miserable
and pompous and po-faced oh i know it's
when he met megan